it features sacrifices of plenty a queen
sacrifice of course is a must in a
brilliant surprise
it features both positionally amazing
ideas and tactically amazing ideas it
features original ideas ideas that i've
never really seen before
ideas by white also that were really
really nice tactical ideas by divirini
that he could have implemented as well
um so that's actually a very important
thing for me it's like it's not a
one-sided game white had his chances
and i think you guys will just see that
taking together all of these things
make this game very deserving of the
brilliant surprise so let's jump in
[Music]
let's take a look at the game of the
year against a sheriff let's leave the
board
uh apologize for the uh technical and
difficulties
of bishop f5 here uh in a slav defense
of bishop f5
and in this position that captures a d5
maybe again matter will analyze this
game i'm actually quite sure that he
will analyze it
sure that he will do a very capable job
of it so it was a slav defense which has
been sure of
weapon of choice for years and years and
years um and he develops the bishop
i will once again go quickly through the
opening which is a very very popular
theoretical line where
basically um white at the cost of
certain structural weaknesses
gets this bishop on on g6 to a place
where it can
it can be captured uh which is exactly
what happens both
both sides develop their pieces here the
viernae captures the pawn sheriff opens
up the h val
and castle's lawn very sharp
continuation
that has you know it's not like the case
that vernee's crazy this has been played
many many times over 170 carlson played
it against vacia
uh in the carlson invitational recently
um
tons of players over 2700 have tried
this
uh including wang hao who has played
this line
four times and
nobody has tried rook takes h2 the
reason is very simple this is act not
actually a sacrifice
he takes takes queen takes b7 wins the
rook so of course you cannot yeah i am a
chess base
and so shirab goes knight beat to d7
do your name discharges the central
tension goes king b1 tucking his king
away this is
all theory um although king b1 is rare
a6 is still common
and this is the point at which shirov
plays a novelty
in a very sharovian style the move that
has been tried seven times previously is
queen to b6 a couple of gm games
and white is maybe slightly better here
um but of course europe didn't want an
end game
and i also think that sheriff didn't
want this queen on b6
blocking the pawn from coming to b5
so actually the move queen to d1 here
would have been very strong for the bna
uh because this queen on b6 is sticking
out it's like the queen alone is not
going to attack so
sure i might have had to waste the time
both queen a7 queen d1 by the way would
have been a novelty so anyone
interested in getting a leg up i think
queen d1 is the strongest move by far in
this position never been played
so somebody repeats this you know this
is what you should do
but for whatever reason sure i played
queen b which is risky
and could have actually been quite
severely punished
now moves like these queen b8 can be
usually punished with blows in the
center so what move
actually i think the correct move is
quite intuitive i i don't
want to trivialize it but what do you
guys think white could have done here
to to try to punish the fact that black
is a little bit cramped right now he's
not
castled yeah so e4 e4 is extremely
strong
now i struggled to figure out why griana
didn't do it
and i think that he didn't do it because
he was afraid sure i would meet the move
with e5
and okay maybe he thought like he didn't
want to give this knight the c5 square i
mean maybe he thought that
this was in shiro's favor but the
reality is now the move bishop c4 comes
in because shirov has
opened up the diagonal and if he castles
now then white piles on the pressure
here it takes takes and
it's this is plus over minus basically
black has to succumb to an end game it's
highly inferior
to he takes d4 takes takes rook a7 and i
don't think the black is losing here
but as you guys can probably just tell
by the position it is very very
unpleasant
um so the movie iv would have given
birnie a serious advantage
okay yes that is an inaccuracy by
sheriff but
because this is still the opening i give
this a pass like i don't believe this
distracts from the game
david plays h4 jump starting his attack
on the king side understandable
he's discouraging black from castling
because he's going to play g4
and he's going to rip black to shreds
with h5 okay
so sure delay is castling and plays b5
now we see a4 by diviri trying to slow
down the progression of black
pawns now we have the advice do not push
the pawn on the same side as your king
is
now that is sometimes true but you have
to take that with a grain of salt
um where you know
white tries to use his pawns to freeze
black spawns so in the case of b4
what would happen is as you can see
black's pawns are frozen and now there's
this b5 square that white can occupy
with his bishop so that was veering his
idea
sure off being sure of is like no no no
i'm castling
be my guest take my pawn obviously
white does not do this that would be
ridiculous
to open up all these files for black and
put the bishop on such a vulnerable
square
with rook b8 to follow with a huge
attack for the pawn
why queen b8 before b5 gp bear asks
absolutely
the reason is that with this move rook
c1 white has x-rayed the queen
and so he threatens a host of nasty
discoveries including knight takes d5 so
you have to move the queen
okay but he's castled so deviorney says
okay first let me take care of some
business and go a5 and freeze the pawns
as he had
tried to do because shuro wanted to kind
of take on a4 here open up the b
file now shurib gets his rook to c8
to the open files virenya develops his
bishop to d3 now he could have gone g4
that was possible
but i think that what do you was think
was thinking that he was in a hurry here
like what black has no attack
what makes this game beautiful is
shirov's ability to manufacture
an attack on the queen side when it
appears that he has
absolutely no attack in sight and this
next move
starts a absolutely incredible sequence
of moves
which i think is just typical syrup and
just worthy of celebration
so he actually the next move is the top
move according to the computer so those
of you who are saying this is just crap
this next move is the top choice of
stock fish 12.
and it comes from the fact that if if
black allows this
well that's just going to be really
nasty so sheriff is like i need to stop
g4
at all costs and he goes queen g3
basically putting his queen in front of
the pawn
attacking it vernee defends it with rook
cg1 but in doing so he has now diverted
a potential defensive resource from the
queen side
um correctly but still now the king is
beginning to feel a little bit lonely
and sheriff pounces with a sacrifice
this next move
is i would say a relatively thematic
sacrifice but nonetheless a very nice
one
so i've given you guys some hints try to
find black snacks move
yeah rook c4 it is
and this is a an exchange sacrifice the
idea being
you can actually take with either pawn i
like the idea of taking with this pawn
and just starting to push the pawns and
yes white is probably better
but the advantage is actually not vast
it's like plus point seven or plus one
which is not that much
and in order to to um show this plus one
white must avoid this move
which loses to b3 and now the attack
gets devastating
so very practical decision by sure of
and a very very typical sacrifice he
loves these exchange stacks
of course if he only sees this and does
not go along with it now
i said part of the reason i chose this
is because
white also had very nice ideas available
at his disposal
and he would only missed one of them
which was h5
sacking the pawn two different ways in
order to open the h file if knight takes
h5
you would go rook h3 double and go g4
and win
because clearly the rook penetration is
deadly
so if g takes h5
that's still rook h3 and now g4 now he
basically invited this pawn to h5
in order to be able to get it out again
and um had h5 been played
shirov would have to go g5 and after h6
to go g6 keeping the file closed
but now uh devierenee having having
introduced
more weaknesses in in black's position
chases the queen away and goes back to
an old plan going e4
with a huge initiative very very nasty
position for black objectively
so this is what vrna could have done but
he goes f4
and he essentially the queen on
on g3 is almost trapped it has no
squares and it now cannot go back so
manca s
and it's nowhere near the queen side
sure's next move deserves applause
now first of all sure could have taken
on d4
which was actually probably the best
move also really nice move
obviously this would have been really
good
now sure i've probably rejected this due
to 92.
winning the rook but how do you get the
most for the rook
how do you do the most for the rogue
bobby fischer says it was great
so rook takes d3 and um
black's got full compensation for the
exchange he's got beautiful square on e4
knight comes out to c5 excellent
position
by sheriff but he plays rook ac8 which
is actually
not bad at all and what amazes me about
this move is the calmness with which he
plays
he doesn't even mind the queen of straps
davioni brings his queen back to d1
further paralyzing black's queen and
again
sheriff continues to attack before and
this was
essentially the critical moment number
one virena goes 92
and he should have gone knight a4 and he
should have gone for a completely
different strategy
very instructive moment rather than
trying to trap the queen
davier should have tried to trade it and
this is actually gives us a very
important lesson that i think derives
from
computer a lot of computer analysis is
that
trapping a queen can be tremendously
difficult but you can use the queen's
compromise position
to actually force a trade and trade can
be
devastating for the side that is
sacrificed
a lot positionally trying to attack so
the reason you go knight a4
is in order to to to uh keep the
diagonal open
for the queen black cannot stop the idea
of queen flow now he's got to move the
rook back
you know it's like the roller coaster
coming down he's got to trade queens
if you take a very close look at this
position white is still attacking first
of all second of all
look at this pawn on a6 and how weak it
is white's gonna go rook c1
he's gonna trade all the rooks and he's
going to take the spawn
black has to go into complete passivity
but now an ip6 comes in
white has several maneuvers this is
extremely nasty
appreciate it like side poker extremely
nasty
for black and so this very non-trivial
idea would have given a big advantage to
the ernie
why queen f3 instead of excellent
questions you know
uh because this trade is a lot worse
positionally for white than the one on
f3
um because now black has access to a
bunch of these holes
now you might be asking but wait a
second can't black go queen g4 here
yes he can but now white can hold the
tension you know
white can continue as if it were an end
game
whereas if you delegate the rook to h3
um the rook on h3 is now stranded
now one more important thing a move like
rook h3 you want to make sure that you
don't assign to the rook
a task that could you know be done
otherwise
so you want to make sure that pieces are
playing to their maximum so this idea
would have been very strong instead of
uranus goes after the queen
and at this one i think he maybe
was expecting i don't know queen f2 and
i think that this is what he was
relying on he goes rook to h3 500 bids
bobby fischer thank you so much
and he goes rook f3 and chapstick but
sure enough
ghost queen g4 and djibouti now realizes
oh
shoot like let me trade queens let me
backpedal
let me backpedal and trade queens and
this is where the amazingness starts
this is where the amazingness starts
all right we need to ban this guy
we need to ban this guy we're at least
time him out for a long time maybe give
him one more chance
but um random messages disrupt the flow
of analysis
random messages disrupt the flow of
analysis my man
okay
so um first of all
if we take then again we get one of
those unpleasant end
this is not as bad for black as as the
previous one was but it certainly is
white holds all the winning chances why
it holds all the winning chances
but shura finds an absolutely stunning
move in this position
and this combination is so beautiful
this move is so beautiful
and it is the only move to keep equality
technically speaking and it is the
correct move
black to play and find a stunning
combination which
i am sure you guys will see why this is
top prize
after you see the move
benjamin buck grandmaster benjamin buck
did you see the game yeah so
i i won't dwell too long at this because
i do want to play some blitz
afterwards so knight to e more
this will go down as one of sherab's
greatest moves
thank you benjamin i appreciate it big
big honor that uh grandmaster watching
and uh
amazing move now let's unpack this it
blunders the queen
sure i've blundered the queen and sure
sure i've now resigned
this was all an elaborate prank sure
i've actually just blundered the queen
and resigned
but i wanted to make fun of the legend
so
i just kidding of course black mates
with the continuation knight takes d2
check
king a1 and now an amazing quiet move
that leads to imminent checkmate
what is it and at this point everybody
should see it
boom rook is opened up you can take the
rook but the one replaces the other
and there is simply no stopping mate now
white can stave it off
you can go knight a2 but the rook
travels and takes the knight
and the comical effect created by look
at look at this
white has twisted around and this just
shows that you need to attack with
urgency
my coach would always say prepare slowly
and attack fast white over prepared the
attack he spent too long
trying to twist his twist himself around
and you know
trying hither and then they're trying to
like get his pieces this way and that
way
he should have just got h5 already and
he pays the price for it in the form of
these pieces
so um really really amazing position now
that's not even the only piece that
duvernay can take he can take the rook
but this is where the amazing part and
this is what i like particularly
every brilliancy that i choose is top
prize has to have a positional element
to it
and the positional elements of this one
is that why i could actually take the
queen
and actually still be much better in the
end game because black has
amazing compensation for the pawn i mean
look at this this other knight is going
to come around to d5 and just visually
i'm not expecting you to see everything
here
black is also threatening c3c2 total
positional domination
despite being done in exchange the
computer evaluates this at a high depth
as
plus 0.5 so a very hefty advantage for
black and from a human perspective
obviously very difficult to play for
white
that is not even the only possibility
you could also take the bishop and with
the same idea
you know you could play in a more
attacking fashion with dc probably this
might be even better
but if you only goes bishop b2 which is
a decisive mistake
the correct move ironically was to take
neither the queen nor the rook but
rather than knight
and go into this endgame and this
end game while it might be slightly
worse for white is
probably equal from an objective
standpoint
because while it might appear that black
gets his knight to a very nice square
white uses the c file to trade both
rooks and remember the a6 pawn is still
weak
so you have to watch over it this is
equal
amazing stuff you don't take the queen
you don't take the rope you take instead
the knight and bail things out
but the very sensibly enough goes bishop
e2
and after queen f5 he goes back to d3
and he basically says
i'm going to hold you together i'm going
to pin you
to which sure responds knight tf6
bringing his knight
in except here's the thing this looks
like a blunder
if black is allowed to get his knight to
g4 the game will be over
there will be too many threats in
particular the threat of knight f2
but this seems to allow de veroni to do
exactly what he wanted to do in the
first place trap his
queen with what move what move seems to
drop black screen and force
black to give up a piece
find it
g4 bingo
i don't have a phone book i have um i'm
actually tutoring someone in history
believe it or not
i have my first um
he's also my chest student but we are
also doing history
so
this is ap world history i i'm just
uh journeying with pages yeah
it's just so you guys know i i have a
life outside of chess
um okay so
this drops the queen it's almost like i
was a history major i mean what kind of
a fraud am i to choose history of all
things to tutor
um
why do you need a tutor for anything
i mean he's also been my student for a
while so um i am not benjamin
actually so anyways this is what makes
this game doubly beautiful even without
this it probably would have won the
billy surprise but sure off
what does he do boom boom
same combination second time around and
this time it works because it wins the
exchange
queen takes g4 knight takes d2
it's very king a1 and now
the move b3 would have won
but it would not have won as simply
because of the move bishop e1 so shiraf
goes for the business approach
boom and here the vernee resigned
because after take stakes
king a2 b3 is
look at this he does the same
combination that involves a queen and a
rook sacrifice
literally twice so to recap this is the
first instantiation
and then this is and it's the same
pieces are hanging
i mean isn't this insane and by the way
if he goes king a2 then b3
and rook a4 yeah the bishop is the
so i think this was rapid
now divirini during his last chance for
equality should have been to take
yeah that was the game now obviously
wasn't perfect no
sure i've made several mistakes gave
virginia several chances e4 here
and maybe like the biggest chance that
vrne really had to just like
change the course of the game was h5 but
he took too long like he was trying to
weave the net for too long he should
have just got on with it
and gone h5 um
so he tries to trap the queen
fails down 94 once and twice
and ends in checkmate and that is my
choice
for the first prize awarded a total of
three points
of the gazprom feed a 2020 olympiad
berlin seat prize
[Music]